are you Amazed by so many chess fans
here coming coming along asking a
photographer they wanted to talk to you
to get your your
signature is this normal for you and
like in the tournaments yeah I mean I
think here in Azerbaijan in Russia a few
other places it's pretty normal so it's
great to see I mean it's kind of weird
because during the games there have been
a few times I go by and kids want to
like ask me for an autograph during the
game which of course you can't do but uh
yeah it's great to see there's so many
fans here and uh hopefully they'll keep
coming as you know there's two free days
for you now the tie break day tomorrow
plus uh rest day what are your plans to
do these two days well what is tomorrow
tomorrow Monday or Tuesday
um I'm not sure but I know it's a tie
break day which you don't have to do and
the next day is resting it makes a big
difference because
tomorrow is Monday I think tomorrow I
lose track of the days here tomorrow
Tuesday I just go stream and play title
Tuesday the real tournament but
um I think tomorrow is Monday if I'm not
mistaken so yeah so we'll see what I do
I'll probably just go into the city
relax and try to enjoy myself
good luck I'm sure